this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by theragun
cbd raycon tushy hello fresh and upstart
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it from the night pants studios
i'm ryan sickler ryansickler.com ryan
stickler on all social media
make sure you sign up for the youtube
channel you get video every tuesday of
all these episodes we've had some
wonderful guests we've got a lot more
coming your way
um and make sure you subscribe to the
patreon channel all right
um it's called the honeydew with y'all
and i am doing
these type of episodes with y'all okay
so far we've talked to
a girl who had two [ __ ] uh we've
talked to two people who've
killed people in self-defense uh we've
talked to
a guy that died we have talked to
yeah a guy that got stalked uh for
a murder he did not commit i i mean we
have we have had some stories
it's five bucks a month okay you guys
always say hey do two a week i can't
always do two a week but i am doing two
a week now and the other one is on
patreon it's
there's no tears or any [ __ ] it's
just five bucks and you get an extra
episode every week
um so 60 bucks a year and you get
52 episodes you know what i mean it's
like a buck and some change
an episode so that's a patreon
and then the website is the
honeydewpodcast.com that's where you can
subscribe to the facebook page that's
where you can go get the merch
okay night pants nation thank you so
much i hope you're comfortable
the night shorts are out there now you
all asked for
these mugs they were out of stock
they're coming all of it's there
and as you know i record here at the
santa monica music center if you live
here in la or anywhere in the country
you can still get
musical lessons you can still get
instruments
uh you can get your online classes from
la musicians here go to santa
monicamusic.com use the code honeydew
they will waive the registration fee
and give you a free lesson when you sign
up for a package all right
that's the santa monica music center you
know we got love for him
now uh you know what we do here we
highlight the lowlights
and uh as i say all the time these are
the stories behind the storytellers
and today very excited to have our
storyteller here
uh i'm sure the santa monica fire
department had saw her titties earlier
equally as excited ladies and gentlemen
jessica
all the right
you can't give it away off the jump they
only saw
something holding the titties they saw
but from a distance
that's the only way to look at titties
you just have to appreciate them from a
distance
until you can earn being up close that's
how you have to do it so then the other
dude who crossed the street walking
saw that and he just looked up and i
said look at him i said what's going on
you were like oh
summer today you are not a woman unless
you flash the fire department you have
to let them know you appreciate them
and that's what i was doing you're a lot
of fun girl um all right we have a lot
to talk about we do i sent you quite a
list you did before we get into it
please
promote everything you want to promote
everything uh you can book me on cameo
to break up with your boyfriend your
mother your stepdad your cousin
i'll sing you a song i don't show my
tits or my butthole not yet i haven't
gotten that desperate yet but i'm not
counting it out because you know what
some [ __ ] are paying their rent with
their toes and their butthole
and i appreciate the hustle uh you can
join my patreon fan club
page the fun house it's on patreon.com
forward slash jessie may
paluso i am really available on on cameo
have you done cameos yet no they keep
asking me to do it but
it's fine i can't bring myself it's so
much fun i can imagine being you
it would probably be a lot of [ __ ]
fun but it me nah
i've welcomed a lot of babies and have
you really yeah
and i've taught husbands the cunnilingus
tricks how are you yeah yeah yeah
what about uh breakups is that real have
you i haven't done breakups
no but you will you would i think it's
hilarious i mean you would call a dude
like sugar ray sugar ray did the breakup
that was like where cameo became popular
oh that's what it was no that's your job
you got to break up with somebody
but i think it's hilarious i appreciate
other people who do it for sure
um what else do i have oh my sharp
tongue podcast you can listen to me on
that
uh bam bong and movie it's my youtube
show where i get stoned and watch a
movie and i'm like the
director's commentary but i'm stoned and
i've never directed anything in my life
i just
love movies and weed
[Laughter]
so that's available every friday a new
movie comes out
um what else i am
um instagram and i'm here with you
you are here yeah i have a book coming
out but that's gonna be a hot minute
about my dad
which we will get to yes i do want to
definitely talk about that so look i
tell me let's start this because you
have such an um
a specific focus here that i really do
want to talk about that but
where are you from originally upstate
new york syracuse all right
upstate new york and you said and what
mom dad brothers sisters
yeah i haven't family i'm the youngest
of four girls
from two different marriages and at one
point i had
sisters from three different marriages
going on
between my mom and my dad and my mom and
her new boyfriend and my dad and his
daughters from before so i've had every
type of traditional
family scenario within one
lifetime okay like on christmases we'd
go to
literally about seven different houses
it was like the world tour of failed
marriages
merry christmas not to all of us
[ __ ]
not to all of us i mean baby's first
christmas how many [ __ ] times are we
gonna do this
so you were not your dad's first child
no i was his last so you weren't even in
the first group of your dad's kid
the first failed marriage i wasn't even
in the first failed marriage no
i was second best always
you're silver yes but of the silver
group
oh okay okay yeah i was the youngest of
all girls
my dad my mom and dad got separated when
i was nine and divorce i don't even know
if they got divorced
the dude's dead there still might be a
marriage floating around in there
somewhere but
yeah i was the youngest of four girls
and grew up in a very
strange upbringing where it just was
it showed me that failure
is around every corner in relationships
but what did it but what did it teach
you it showed you that but what did that
also
teach you it well from a really
realistic
and psychological level
it taught me to be comfortable in chaos
which can be useful
but that's toxic can i ask you a
question yeah in chaos when you've had
moments of
chaos in your life like
does it slow down for you sometimes
yeah it definitely i feel comfort in it
i've definitely felt comfortable in
not that it comforts me but i have felt
comfort in places where people normally
should
not sure so in a way my and that's and i
i had
plenty of love i always say that if if
my parents didn't love me
i'd be on a pole like i was one
you know or two parents who didn't love
me away from being
becoming a stripper but because they
loved me so much
all of the chaos sort of balanced itself
out
that love is so important and they
didn't do the tug and pull that a lot of
parents do in failed marriages where
they use their children as a tennis ball
right in their you know emotional racket
but it it definitely taught me
the that relationships
should have some level of lacking
respect of lacking um
a healthy balance
between two people because i witnessed a
lot of
you know disrespect between people a lot
of language that shouldn't be said
between two people
who supposedly love each other and have
children and and not just between my mom
and dad between
you know family other family members
so it definitely taught me that
the re a regular relationship is
unhealthy and an
unhealthy relationship is normal right
so i struggled through that for years
yeah and then you learn that's the hard
part for me too is i learned to
actually thrive in the chaos yeah and
once i realized
wait a minute if we can figure this
[ __ ] chaos out we could probably do
even way better
you know i'm saying like let's take that
junior varsity to varsity
well that's where comedy came in for me
because i didn't know
how to thrive in the chaos so i just
found out a way to divert it
but it's so interesting what you said
you said i became and it resonated with
me as you said i was like huh you said i
became comfortable in situations where
most people weren't comfortable and
stand up is
a situation where 99
of people on this planet probably would
not be comfortable doing that and for me
and i'm sure the same for you it's no
matter
what [ __ ] i have going on in my life
when i am on that stage
it does not for for 15 minutes or an
hour
it does not enter my brain for us not
even a millisecond
not even a millisecond so it's it is
weird and that's
that's such an interesting thing that
you say that like oh yeah that's what
stand is it's exactly it's complete
chaos
is the most chaotic yes thing in the
world yeah you've got a room full of
people you don't know
you're about to divulge your deepest
darkest secrets if you you know you're
being
truthful with yourself if you're if
you're appreciating the art and the
craft that is stand up
you're wasting your stage time if you
aren't divulging your demons i agree
and that's not normal if the only time
that that's normalized in society is
with the therapist you're paying
and we've chosen to use a room full of
strangers and youtube
and youtube and youtube
i need your laugh on my phone
people keep asking people keep asking me
for
a ringtone on my laptop but is that a
thing do people use ringtones
it's going that we're changing my room
and down they're coming back yeah we are
going to and i'm going to be in trader
joe's or someplace
like is there a pterodactyl in here i
thought i had a crazy
dolphin in the back over um
all right so i do want to get into this
because you say as a young age so we're
talking about you growing up and you say
you have many me too moments
at from a young age so yeah well you i
know you are comfortable talking about
it so i'm not going to ask you if you
are because i already talked about it on
stage
yeah but can we start with the first
like what age are we talking about that
this begins
well it's such a strange thing because
the popularity of the me too moment was
baffling to me it was baffling on two
different levels
one that it took so long and two that
there were
parts of it that were being utilized for
personal gain
which totally negates the truthful side
of the metoo movement
and as a woman it's just you're dodging
dicks
you are dodging okay listen i believe it
all basis
and then you're not only dodging dicks
you're dodging dudes who are telling you
to [ __ ] deal with it
just deal with it it thoughts deal with
it that's what happens when you got tits
in the [ __ ] you gotta [ __ ] deal with
it i get the jerk off on this boss
[ __ ] deal what do you think you put
on earth for you gotta take care of a
man's needs
and then there's the other side of of
men who are actually respectful and girl
dads like yourself who don't
speak like that or don't view women like
that but you [ __ ] haven't been
loud enough
so from a young age you know the first
dick i saw
was on some [ __ ] guy how old are you
i was probably 11 at the time
i was going i was going to get
milk for my mom oh my god
where like to a little syracuse new york
wilson
market it might have been wilson's are
you walking are you riding your bike
i'm walking i got my little kids on the
shoelaces are you by yourself
i'm with my friend amy my shoelaces are
half tied cause i'm [ __ ] 11.
uh i probably have some dirt on my knee
because i was a tomboy
you know a little bit of sweat because
it was a hot summer day in syracuse and
the sun was high
clear sky couldn't have been a more
beautiful day and amy and i are skipping
because we're innocent and we still have
our hymens and we're just enjoying
we didn't start horseback riding so it
was like 15. you know
i mean a deep sneeze will make that
thing snap off
but for the most part
[Laughter]
but i mean all was good in the world
yeah
i was so beautiful what's not i and i
don't mean funny in a [ __ ]
comical way but you remember this is a
thing about trauma
every detail there wasn't a cloud in the
sky
my hymen was intact my shoes were on top
i have to put that in my book
please please put my hymen was still
intact
you know like when you buy food it's
such a specific
you buy like packaged vegetables and
there's that layer of plastic you have
to peel off
yeah it was still there it was just
there and it was happy
and everything was just so beautiful and
fun and
nothing had tainted my youth now we've
got hymans and taints okay
they're not at coachella this year
hymans and taints will not be at the
main
echo channel that's that's my next shirt
just diamonds and tapes
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor
thera1 cbd from tight muscles tough
workouts signs of aging to simply making
it through each busy day
everyone understands what it feels like
to be tense and sore so
everyone can benefit from thera1 cbd
products started by jason wersland thera
body exists to provide you with the best
scientifically validated natural
solutions to help you soothe your body
and relax your mind it started with the
revolutionary thera-gun
percussive therapy device when dr jason
saw the benefits of using cbd and his
treatments he created thero1
to bring you cbd products done right a
lot of cbd products claim organic
but still contain up to 30 filler and
these fillers are potentially toxic
thera1 tests their products four times
before they get to you
every product is usda certified organic
grown here in the u.s
and their cbd extracts are the highest
quality available
anywhere use thera1's warming lotion in
your morning routine the cooling lotion
or massage oil will recover the body
bomb for targeted relief and the sleep
tincture
to drift into a deep night sleep i've
been using
the gun i've been putting it on hitting
this shoulder here man i don't know what
it is my knee i had arthroscopic surgery
when i was 14 back in the day and like
hey that's going to come back to haunt
you and guess what the haunted house
woke up so i've been using
uh thera1 all over it it really does
work it really makes me feel better
all right so here's the deal let me hook
you guys up all right so now through
labor day which is monday september 7th
there one's offering my listeners a
buy one get one free for all thera1
products okay you've got to go to
theragun.com
honeydew and if you don't love what you
get from thera1
send it back for a full refund within 30
days of purchase this is not something
there one is likely to do again
it is buy one get one free at thera
theragun
that's t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n dot com slash
honeydew
but only until labor day go right now to
theragun.com
honeydew our next sponsor is upstart
during these economically turbulent
times
everyone's looking for a way to feel
more financially secure so if you're
still needlessly throwing money every
month at high interest credit card debt
it's time you checked out upstart the
revolutionary online lending platform
that knows you're more than just a
credit score
now is the time to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
to help pay off high interest credit
card debt unlike other lenders upstart
can reward you
based on your education and your job
history in the form of a smarter rate
so you don't need a degree or diploma to
apply though upstart lets you skip going
to the bank because it's completely
online they offer loans from a thousand
dollars
to 50 000 so you can consolidate your
debt into one
easy fixed rate payment upstart makes it
fast and simple to check your rate
since it's just a soft pull it does not
affect your credit score
the hard pull happens if you accept your
rate and proceed with your application
and the best part
is if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business day now over
000 people have used upstart to pay off
credit cards
or meet their financial goals so free
yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstart
see why upstart has a 4.9 out of 5
rating on trustpilot and hurry to
upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
honeydew now let's get back to the duke
oh my gosh
and her and i were walking down the hill
right
adjacent to wilson's market and across
the street came this creature
of a man a behemoth big
bulbous body frame in a bowl cut
and i could he was so far away but i
knew he had drool on his face i just
knew he did he just had the
sound of something that was drooling he
had a red t-shirt on
with red shorts and how old would you
say older
teenager it was hard to tell because he
was he was definitely
you know mentally disabled some sort of
either
a mixture of down syndrome mabel maybe
like a little fetal alcohol syndrome
mixed
in there like it definitely was a a
cocktail of mental retardation
and it was coming at us
and screaming and i thought he was
injured amy and i
stopped and we're like what is this and
he was like
like he couldn't speak but he was trying
to get to us
and he hiked up his shorts up
i know well which is an
invasive way to show
[Music]
i got their shorts to [ __ ]
let me show you about that girl look at
it
look at it and then it's just like now
what are you gonna do
it's just it's all hot the side of your
shorts it's so hot it's so loose
he hiked the red shorts up they were how
close is he to you now he's still
running he's
probably a good 100 feet away
he had stopped once we both looked at
him i think we scared him because
he had a plan i think he he just woke up
and was like i'm going to show someone
my dick
this was a maiden voyage for both of us
i honestly i love i love mentally
challenged people i love
[ __ ] whatever you want to call
whatever the word is my mom was always
around them and we had a kid she used to
watch who'd come over and
my mom taught you know she was like a um
teaching assistant
for mentally challenged people so i was
used to kind of being around them and in
this instance i was like oh he must need
help there's something wrong like he's
yelling at us and so we look and he
stops
and he he like and then he hikes up his
shorts
and it it just kind of peeks out like
a kitten paw under a door when you're in
the bathroom
little pig ball
it's ridiculous and
i didn't know what it was i was gonna
say yeah right i had no
point i had no contact you had never
seen a picture or
nothing the first one you're seeing is
alive in person
alive in person from afar on the
frame the physical and mental frame of
somebody who doesn't even understand the
depths of what they're doing sure
and it was this was probably you know he
it was almost like as innocent as a
young girl and a young
boy or young two young girls or two
young boys experiencing something for
the first time together
it just was in this weird you know
juxtaposition of a grown
mentally challenged person and a young
girl which probably together we would
have made a great cup
[Laughter]
we probably were par for par pretty
mentally
you know you clearly remember everything
about this did you
yeah did you scream did you run what was
your immediate reaction i honestly
thought it was a kitten
i thought he had a kitten i thought he
had tucked a kitten
into his shorts and that
he like that it was falling i didn't
know i honestly i hear you're
11.
my friend amy's like no because she had
been around
the dick already and i was like what
what
is it she goes no no no
that's his penis and then she screams
and then we run into wilson's market
and you know i still got my mom the
[ __ ] milk
but you know i don't even remember if i
did mr mrs wilson
say something inside were they like
what's going on out there girl johnson's
he's always out gary's always out what
is it tuesday yeah
gary flash is the cat on tuesdays
and that was my listen don't come up
here tomorrow
on wednesdays how many body parts are
left
so you know the other side of like
things like this do you go home and tell
anyone do they explain to you like what
happens
where do you who do you talk to about
well that's that's what i was going to
touch on is there's this
conversation it's like why didn't you
say anything when things happen to women
it's evolving now thankfully why didn't
you say anything well we didn't
exactly grow up in a society that made
us feel comfortable
nor do we grow up with parents who had
the self-awareness
and psychological um
tools to communicate with their children
about
things in society that they may come up
against and what to expect and how to
sort of handle those things so
we didn't have the tools to talk about
things like that happening to us
we just didn't because we were hushed
for so long you know it takes a while
for those
things to evolve and i don't even think
i don't even think i really told my mom
i might have told her there was like a
weird guy but i can't
maybe i'm remembering wrong but i i
really don't remember having like
mom there's this guy and i thought it
was a cat but it was a dick here's the
two percent like i don't remember
baby it was scam i'm gonna need you to
go back like i can't i can't see that
again not twice in the same day man and
listen i can't go tomorrow honey did you
get two percent
no we need skim milk you know i have
issues you can go tomorrow
mm-hmm we cannot go tomorrow you don't
go to wilson
squeeze in his butthole his dirt starts
winking at me from across
that's definitely one of the days i
think i'd take the ball over the penis
at this point i would i would yeah
but that was the first time i ever saw
one and you know it was a
a lot of the maiden voyages for
a girl a young girl like seeing her
first penis if she's
uh heterosexual or first time having sex
or like
relationships a lot of those things were
robbed of me
yes they were forced on me they were
scenarios that i didn't have
a say in and so all these little
milestones that
females are should have in their life
like you being a girl dad
you don't want those things forced on
them that they should experiencing
they should be experiencing them with
some innocence in youth and
in respect so most of those milestones
in my life were completely robbed
and it was a situation where i just had
to react
so it it really made me
sort of have to view the world in this
like well now
i'm literally i have to dodge dick it
made me defensive like
you know i used to talk about it on
stage i was like a dick ninja i had to
like
there were you know i'm chopping them
left and right
trying to like defend myself like some
sort of kill bill [ __ ]
i mean i remember reading an article
about a woman this is just a few years
ago on the
chicago subway and she's like look these
guys
i'm gonna get there's gonna be a guy
who's gonna grind his dick against me
for
15 stops and i know it and i'm used to
it
and i put up with it i'm like god yeah
and then
and the other thing too like and another
friend recently said it to me she's like
you know you don't even you don't even
think twice when a woman walks past you
on the sidewalk because if she were
crazy or to attack you
chances are unless she's some mma chick
that's gonna whip my ass i i got it yeah
you got it
right whereas she's like i worry about
every man that walks
past me i don't care what time of day
and then it hit me like
[ __ ] yeah we've had to be on the defense
of everything
yeah and i i mean when you walk in my
shoes and my skin
and my experiences i don't even see that
because i've always been the protector
of the woman i've been with right now
i'd also be like shut the [ __ ] up i do
not want to fight that yeah a lot of
people are like don't ruin your mouth
right now
get the car started please let me just
enjoy my crab legs [ __ ] let me just
finish
dinner we didn't even finish our
appetizer
[Laughter]
can we wrap up the melon please so tell
me you said
you had a boss you said yeah i had a
boss i worked at a pizza shop
in upstate new york sixteen so high
school game
team one of my first jobs i did work at
the
grocery store wegmans when i was younger
but i couldn't handle math
what was the name of the pizza place oh
i can't remember the name of it yeah
wilson's wagmans what the [ __ ] is this i
know it was
w i know i don't even remember it
and how old was this boss oh college or
older
older oh really yeah like late thirties
i was like
16 17 at the time yeah so what happened
well i was preparing like
salad stuff i was in the back chopping
up lettuce
and he used to buy the cheapest [ __ ]
ingredients man like i
i'm all i get the margin i respect the
margin but this [ __ ] was buying
lachuga off the back of a truck that had
been
wilted even the flies were like oh
and the just the ingredients were so bad
everything about this place was
screaming cheap and gross and
i'm back there just chopping up the
lettuce he
comes from his office and has a raging
boner
it is noon he's walking out like that
he's just walking out in his cargo
shorts
and his stupid polo t-shirt and his
shitty
dad new balance sneakers with crappy
socks
and a boner at noon and i had just
barely
healed from the you know the [ __ ] dick
across the street from wilson's market
two years prior here comes another one
packaged in these cargo shorts off a
sail rack from kmart
and he just grabs my hand and puts it on
his dick
like over his pants over his pants and
doesn't say anything he goes you want
that
and i'm like i don't know is it a new
pizza topping
i'm wondering where your [ __ ] you keep
the croutons okay
you think you were the best to laugh at
this [ __ ]
i'm crying
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor tushy now
everyone has an
ass and everyone deserves the gift of
tushy wiping your butt with dried toilet
paper does not remove all the [ __ ]
okay if you've got poop on any other
part of your body
would you just wipe it off with dry
paper no water cleans better than dry
paper my friends
thankfully now there's a sleek new bidet
attachment
that clips onto your existing toilet and
sprays your butt completely clean with
fresh water it's called
tushy and it's the best thing you can do
for your butt tushy sprays directly to
your ass
and it removes the poop completely so
you aren't sitting on bacteria that
leads to nasty things like hemorrhoids
yeast infections utis itchy [ __ ]
skid marks and the back of your ball
stank
all right bidets are common in the rest
of the world a bidet saves you money on
toilet paper you still use a little
toilet paper to pat dry but the amount
is negligible it will not clog your
toilet until she sprays your ass with
fresh water okay it's not toilet water
tushy connects to the water supply
behind your toilet to spray your dirty
parts with clean
fresh water it's the exact same water
you brush your teeth with
wet wipes are worse than toilet paper
they're terrible for the environment
they cause anal fissures you do not want
your anus fissuring
this thing is only 79 okay it's an
it's an attachment that's 79 bucks okay
and they also have a tushy ottoman
which helps you get everything out it's
like a sexy tooth or a cloud that helps
you poop
and that's only 69 okay and that's nice
all right now here's the deal go to
hellotushy.com
honeyduke and get 10 off your order and
free shipping that's hello tushy
t-u-s-h-y dot com slash honeydew
get 10 off your order and free shipping
wash your ass our next sponsor is hello
fresh get fresh pre-measured ingredients
and mouth-watering
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door with hellofresh
america's number one meal kit i don't
know why i waited so long
i don't know i always feel like i'm not
going to be good at these things i've
tried some in the past but
hello fresh is literally my favorite one
right now they let you skip those trips
to the grocery store they make home
cooking fun easy and affordable you can
do it the kids
their recipes are so delicious they
offer so many recipes to choose from
each week to help you break out of your
recipe rut
there's something for everyone including
low calorie vegetarian and family
friendly recipes every week that's picky
eaters
hellofresh offers fresh high quality
ingredients every week for a super
favorable experience
over 90 percent of the ingredients are
sourced directly from growers to ensure
the freshest
recipes are delivered to your door you
can save time and stress
effortlessly hellofresh offers
contactless delivery to your doorstep
for easy home cooking with the family
hello fresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and grocery store trips you can
enjoy
cooking get dinner on the table in just
about 30 minutes or even 20 minutes with
their quick recipe options
so go to hellofresh.com honeydew80
all right and you use the code
honeydew80
to get a total of 80 off all right
including free shipping on your first
box
additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com
for more details now again i'm going to
say it again hellofresh.com
honeydew 80. all right
do it up let's get back to the dew
something's going on in that office this
dude walks out with a raging heart on
grabs it says do you want that and i
mean
i didn't know i i didn't even know first
hard on i didn't know what it was oh
yeah because his wasn't his was just
no his was across the street and dead
yeah he looked like
he's looked like newborn dead kitten
roadkill
and and this was and this is a grown
man's boner
grown boner a groaner right here
[Laughter]
right here right here like i i i
i remember it and i just was like what
the [ __ ] what what what are you doing
i'm just
i'm trying to make your your pizzas i'm
here just
just as a job trying to save enough
money so i can go to darien lake
i i don't know what this is
still didn't tell my mom no no because i
was like
but did you say anything to him or did
he treat you differently after that was
he scared was he
defensive was he yeah he kind of he
definitely treated me
a little bit differently like he was
trying to suck up to me and
a little bit of like scared he got
scared and trying to do like a little
manipulative thing and then
he ended up hiring this dude who just
got out of jail
they called him the ice cream man he had
just gotten out of jail because he had
an ice cream truck
that he was it was a really smart
business plan he had an ice cream truck
that he made actual ice cream out of but
then he sold drugs to the parents
yeah smart smart deal great summer gig
ask for like the [ __ ] uh
you know the dead cat pops how much you
want bro
got two ounces of columbia dead
relatives
[Laughter]
[Music]
he hired this dude and just was like the
energy was so bad i just i made up some
excuse to my mom why i couldn't work
there anymore you know just
something i never told her never no or
anyone she was gonna find that around
she should probably find out now
now sorry mom did you have any friends
you could confide in or any girls that
you could
you could share that with or sisters i
mean still amy and i were still very
very close
and my sister was four years older than
me and at that point she was
just in college so she wasn't really
around that much
i didn't really have you know besides my
friend amy i didn't really have a lot of
you know people to confide in not that i
didn't feel comfortable confiding my mom
her and i are very very close but this
is also a time in an era where
like i said that communication factor
wasn't something that was a prominent
thing in a family you know maybe some
people grew up like that but
not necessarily in this instance and i
also was scared like
totally i i was starting to get so much
on the defense i was like is something
wrong with me
like why wh why is this coming towards
me and a lot of women do that a lot of
girls do that they just
assume that it's their fault they take
it on themselves and
i think i struggled with that a lot and
it just
you know when i look at especially just
you know sending that
list of things that i sent to you when i
was pooping
all the time you said you were pooping
when you read it
um i would feel comfortable talking to
you on the phone when i poop that's
that really feels nice yeah thank you i
would i appreciate that i want you know
that
um i i don't think i've ever really
looked at the spectrum of things that
i've
done in one chunk like that and after i
sent it i was like
oh wow [ __ ] listen i sent it to ash
this morning uh and he was like holy
[ __ ]
i was like that's what i'm doing and
saying
yeah it's been you know it's disturbing
i mean just the bullet points of that
you have the can we talk about your
uncle that was the one you listened to
yeah
yeah and how you tell me just i'll show
you it was
you know that was really difficult um
for me it was somebody who was very
close to me
and um was
had a job that also was a very
disturbing job to have for somebody who
did what he did he
he ended up kind of
abusing one of my friends for years so
how do you
how old was he i want to say he was like
in his
mid 30s to early 40s and who's
how's he your uncle mom's brother
brother like separated like a
through divorce type of thing but you
know when i was growing up we had this
great
place where we'd go to as a kid um this
lake
and my mom sort of grew up there as a
child and so
there's a lot of times in the summer we
go every summer as family when my mom
and dad were together we'd go
and we'd hang out for a couple weeks and
and my uncle also had a place there and
so a huge group of your family yeah and
it was like a really of
like a tradition of ours and even after
my parents separated my dad loved it so
much that we continued to go
as you know my dad and i and my sister
and my father just loved it there and
even after through
separations and stuff my uncle was still
up there so we just we'd all hang out it
was like the most
like it's so strange for me to recall it
because it was such an amazing time but
also
so tainted and
uh muddied with what
happened that it's hard to to
think about it with fond memories
without
really knowing yeah or feeling what was
going on and having that
sort of taint the whole
memory of it but yeah he he for years
was
right under our noses so you would bring
a friend up with you
and you know it took one year it was
years of it going on and then one summer
how old was she when it started maybe
like high school
younger than that younger yeah
and you know one day her and i are just
sitting there and
she was like you know your your
uncle does makes me do things to him and
i don't know what to do how old is she
at this point i think she was like
15 or 16. it's been going on for a while
oh
and you know it's so i've never really
like talked about it out loud
i might have you know told some friends
about it but that's the problem
staying silent is the problem and it's
been a problem for so many people
and you know things like this
imprint on people they change things
like that
changed the way like the relationships
i had the trust
trust issues that i had so to have to
remain
silent is torture
you know it's it's on it's unfair
it is it's not it's because you should
be allowed to heal
so and this girl at least is brave
enough to tell you
yeah she's taking her years obviously
right in years
not one time can you imagine being her
and not wanting to ruin our time
she's feeling terrible everything going
into it
just so [ __ ] up on so many levels and
and we couldn't so she tells me and i
don't even know what that meant because
i hadn't been sexually active at that
point
i hadn't done anything before she i mean
was your
your uncle was probably her first i mean
there were sections
there was some there yeah there was some
stuff going down that
as a dad you would probably want to
punch
or murder something i was going to say
kill yeah that would be
probably your you know your reaction
in your car [ __ ]
[Laughter]
where's that security system um
but i remember not even knowing what she
was saying you know not even
it's just blowing your mind yeah well i
just didn't know i didn't have anything
to
compare it to besides your uncle yeah
yes
yes i'm like i only know what kitten
dick in the sausage sandwich
sausage sandwich i'm like what
i don't even know i just remember being
like
you know you know when people tell like
a joke or mention somebody who's
prominent you don't know who it is but
you're like
oh yeah whoa you just act like you're
shocked
like you know what's going on but you
don't have any context that's what it
was
so what do you do we i was like well
let's tell emily
because we were up at this camp emily my
sister is that his
your my it's that you're from your first
my mom and my dad yeah
my first group yep my first she's the
only my only full blood sister
okay um and we sort of you know
let her know and i see that she knows
what it is
because at that point she was a hoe no
i'm just kidding
i love you emily no she was you know she
was a grown she was like
you know in her late teens she was she
was a you know a young woman at that
point
she would definitely know what you're
talking about yeah she got
so angry so angry and so concerned for
for my friend and and and then she's
like we can't tell dad
because we were there for another week
oh she's like if we we have one
we have two choices we leave and go home
and deal with this right now
or i'll run into jets
i would lose all my deposit we can't i
got three wave runners on hold
we got two paddle boats that we will not
get our money back on
i got us the good pontoon with a slide
off the summer
ice cream social is on saturday
oh my god we didn't know what to do with
so much pressure for young girls to try
and figure out
i mean just down to the minutiae
[ __ ] of we got another week
at this summer thing yeah say something
like
it's as if it's not hard enough just to
come forward and say it at all it's like
now you got to put vacation
time on yeah you know you know we just
daddy ain't getting paid for three of
these days you know what
happened we only have six more days in
summer
school starts
so we stayed for another week all three
of us knowing that
knowing and not saying anything but wait
is he
coming on to her and everything well
still at this point or she now fighting
it now she's like
hey she's got now that she's she's got
security she's got security
she's like she does feel comfortable
telling him no now right
okay and um
i don't know if i'm gonna get any
backlash from my family talking about
this but it's been years
and i really don't i don't give a [ __ ]
in the sense because
i've had to carry that burden for so
[ __ ] long and it affected
and changed the fiber of who i am
and i don't regret anything in life all
the struggles i've had
have shaped me into a resilient woman
but not without
going through some very detrimental
infringements on my innocence and i can
also imagine
seeing these [ __ ] monsters this kid
at the market this guy at the pizza
place and then all of a sudden it's your
in your family like what someone you
trusted
someone you can and now it's in your
house and in your on your
vacation i imagine that's gotta [ __ ]
with your mind
so hard yeah we're not safe anywhere
no and that and that's that's even
before
i've even been sexually active that's
even before i really had like a real
boyfriend so all these things are
shaping and yeah you're this is what
you're this is your sex
ed yep is just [ __ ] predators right
exactly
exactly and i'll never forget
he comes over one day because we were
all going to go to a drive-in movie
and my sister and i were like what do we
do she's like we have to play it
as cool because if he suspects
something's going on
it'll change the vibe of everything and
it'll blow up so if we want to try and
have some control over this
we got to sort of deal with it
he comes over and there was another
young girl in his front
the front seat you know passenger c
and she was a you know young girl and
we're like who's this he's like oh this
is the neighbor's kid i
said that she could come with us to go
to the movie
now any other scenario it would be
innocent
but with the new revelation yes it was a
pattern of behavior
i didn't know then but now as an adult i
understand
from thanks to a lot of netflix
documentaries and shows and information
and articles
that there's a grooming process that
happens especially
when it when it's an older person when
it's like a pedophile situation
there's a grooming process that happens
yeah i didn't even know that term until
like within the last few well
yeah last few years of having a child
like wait that's a a thing and it's got
a term
like yeah yeah the whole michael jackson
thing opened my eyes up to groom
what what the term grooming is when
oprah's talking about it on there like
you're groomed i was like
it's a deep premeditated
manipulation and a stripping of of
youth and innocence and can we jump back
for one second
what you stay another week at this camp
is this movie happening there just
driving yeah it's
it's we yeah we just like all go and
drive to like a drive-in movie which
sounds like it's the 19th
during this camp like this week where
you're all shutting up okay so you
haven't left and gone back home and now
we're we stayed
yeah i mean that's weird go ahead it's
weird because if it
if you'd have been like oh this is cindy
you're going to want anything oh yeah
the more the merrier but yeah knowing
what we knew
everything at that moment changed it all
changed
all the it's sort of like that
retrospect
once i started to know in in and she
told us everything that was going on and
you look backwards you're just like
oh my god how was he do how
how how the [ __ ] did he get away with it
when on jet ski rides when we were
playing hide and seek when
you know we would have movie nights
right
under our literal noses literally right
under our noses and we had no idea
and this is you know
i have and i have i have empathy for him
because i truly believe
in my heart of hearts that he is a
product of something
so much more toxic that that is his
pattern of behavior i have empathy for
that
because he's a product of a society that
built that
he was created this isn't something that
you know i truly believe that's not you
don't just you're not like oh this is
like
i'm gonna try this out it's not like
[ __ ] honey
honeydew melons yeah right right you
know what i i just don't think it's like
that
right so i have empathy for it but
it it honestly you know you look
backwards and you just realize
how robbed you felt because it was all
happening right under your nose and it
in it
all those memories you're like that was
all lies
so when do you guys finally we go home
blow the whistle
after we go home and write like the day
we got back
she told her mom we sat down with my dad
and my mom and we told them
and then collectively do you remember
their reactions was it
anger was it sadness my mom wasn't
surprised
wow isn't that always trippy too when
somebody's like doesn't surprise me
yeah in in she had kind of
forewarned us lightly once really
she had kind of forewarned us a little
bit just to sort of
you know keep our wits about us and you
know be
you know be strong and and sort of kind
of
know that something i think it was like
something had happened
when he was younger with one of her
sisters or something and she's like just
because we were starting to hang out a
lot with him before and so she had she'd
said like one
thing and so when this became a
revelation
she felt really bad she felt
hurt sad for my friend and
just really concerned about us and
making sure that nothing had happened to
us
right um what happened to him ultimately
who confronted him we went to the police
i remember this and we had to give you
know we had to get separated my friend
and i and give our stories or recounts
of what happened
and um
he got community service that's
it and he got to go back to his job
teaching
teaching oh man
are you [ __ ] kidding me how how does
that because
even better because even back then but
society even though we are an advanced
society
on a on a psychological level we are so
behind we are so behind because we've
allowed our egos to drive our ships for
so long
and egos can't drive the ship it has to
be your yourself and you have to be
self-awareness and we need a society
where
people can feel comfortable and
supportive
supported in their own individual demons
he's he's got demons demons deep deep
demons
giving those demons to who god knows how
many others right
yeah and society's failing him yes
because
we're we were raised in a just deal with
it
right culture just walk it off
they all say whatever you want just walk
it the [ __ ] off
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy like you i i
feel
i feel empathy for men because when you
guys are when you're
boys and sons when you're younger and
you cry
usually nine times out of ten the
parents gonna be like don't cry
not why are you crying talk to me tell
me what's going on don't cry you're a
boy boys don't cry
that's that's traditionally been a
conversation for young boys
and that's not fair yeah you're
devaluing their emotions right from the
start
so right from the start as young girls
we're taught that
you're going to be dodging dick and you
have to be defensive
and you can't trust people and again
this is just from my experience
but from the jump boys are taught that
your emotions are not
they're not valid and whatever you're
feeling whatever pain hurt or fear you
have
it's not real so tuck it down and go
kick that ball right
and then that's a rinse and repeat
that's the vicious cycle of of
upbringing and rearing that we have with
children it's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up so then is he are you
guys just like you're dead to us you
don't talk he's out
yeah but he gets to live a normal life
and your poor friend
has probably severe [ __ ] trauma
yeah [ __ ] it was it broke a lot of
relationships
it destroyed a lot of families yeah the
ripple effect was
huge huge and still lasting
um well are you comfortable talking
about the first time you had sex
yeah i mean yeah i mean i'm probably
disowned by my family from that but sure
just talking about truth truth hurts um
yeah the first time my introduction
is this entertaining for people
yes are you sure yeah they're gonna be
like oh yeah
no you're gonna get you're gonna get so
much love from this
um but the fact that you're sitting here
still laughing through
any of this [ __ ] you're talking about it
shows how strong you are and how strong
my marijuana is
smoke weed every day let's take a quick
break and tell you about our next
sponsor raycon whether you're working
from home or working on your fitness you
want what you're listening to
to be what you're listening to not what
your roommate or your neighbor or your
significant other or your kids are
listening to
everyone needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds but before you go dropping
hundreds of dollars on a pair you need
to check out the wireless earbuds from
raycon look i've got two
pairs of raycon now my stepson took the
up the brand new ones i can't even get
them back from him
he's taking everything and he's like i
love them they're the best earbuds i've
ever had you already know
raycon earbuds started about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and that they
sound just as amazing
as other top audio brands you know but
their newest model the one my stepson
took from me the everyday e25 earbuds
are their best ones yet and that's why
he took them
with six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit raycon's wireless
earbuds are so comfortable
they're perfect for conference calls or
uh
binging podcasts uh what made him a game
changer for me i
you know i had the wires hanging all the
time i traveled with them when i was
traveling all the time coming out to see
you guys um and i walk around the house
now doing conference calls on them
cleaning
stuff like it you know nothing in the
way you could do whatever you want
and unlike some of your other wireless
options raycon earbuds are both stylish
and discreet with no dangling wires or
stems to distract anyone
during your video calls and you've heard
me talk about how the company was
co-founded by ray j and celebrities like
snoop dogg cardi b
you know i love me some cardi b and they
are all obsessed with raycon
so pick up a pair and see what the hype
is all about and now is the time
to get the latest and greatest from
raycon you can get 15 percent
off your order at buyraicon.com
honeydew that's buy raycon
r-a-y-c-o-n.com
honeydew for 15 all for acom wireless
earbuds
by raycom.com honeydew
now let's get back to the do i yeah the
first time i ever had sex
i was raped god what how
were you 16. this happened shortly after
the revelation with my friend so all
this [ __ ] and then here comes this now
now it's like this guy say goodbye to
your hymen it was like when those
magicians come up and they pull the
tablecloth
and everything stays well the tablecloth
got yanked that's my hymen and
everything went to [ __ ]
what was he a boyfriend were you dating
someone i trusted
and i yeah i was gonna say how old was
he
19. okay 20. oh so he's rough dude
and you're underage underage he was a
bouncer at my uncle's club
i used to sneak into the same uncle no
no
um my cousin's actually my cousin who's
a bouncer at my cousin's club
area 51 was the name of the club and you
guessed it there is alien decor
all over the phone he took the name and
ran
with it ran with it he had a
like blow up alien dolls spacecrafts was
lighting up the dance floor
and it was one of the bouncers i was
like oh this guy with the neck tap with
a tribal neck tattoo
he'll love me i can fix it he'll respect
me
he definitely won't shove his dick in my
hand
um it's you know i started to
display those behaviors of somebody
who's
been abused
even though the abuse was a little bit
indirect it still was abuse that i was
witnessing
and i made it very clear that i wasn't
ready
for anything physical i just wasn't
because all the stuff i had witnessed
man i was like sex looks [ __ ]
terrible
yes like you either have to like force
it
on somebody or do it with a kid why are
people even [ __ ] this is really
yeah this is really scary stuff that
makes sense
i knew nothing about like you know
you're still only 16 at that age what
the [ __ ] do you know
yeah nothing yeah no fingering under the
bleachers
trying to parallel park all right just
trying to learn how to parallel park
right now
that's all i want to do i just wanted to
get fingered under the bleachers
too much
italian boss with gelled hair and a
[ __ ] figaro link necklace
god i was robbed of so many good moments
i just wanted to get fingered by a
sweating weird teenager i might have to
go back
i'm going to be a teacher who [ __ ] kids
just to relive
the re-livery that's what's probably
happening
um yeah and i made it very clear to him
i just wasn't ready for anything
physical i
i didn't have a grasp on it and i didn't
i wasn't developed in that way yet
and there was one night where you're
supposed to go to the movies
carousel mall in syracuse new york shout
out to carousel mall which is now
destiny usa yeah destiny yeah the only
it's the only it's destiny for covid
that's all it's destiny for at this
point i'm sure the mall is not even
really kicking but
it was it was a popular spot and we were
going to go to a movie
and he was like oh i want to show you
something the movie the mall i lived
really close to the mall it was like a
mile drive
and when it gets on the highway it goes
on opposite direction i was like oh the
mall's that ways again but i want to
show you something and i was like okay
so we pull to the back of this like
now in syracuse all the businesses like
90
of them are houses and the business is
like a nail salon or a bar
there's so many bars that are houses
it's like there's linoleum and a
stripper pole
yeah it's like is this a kitchen no it's
a strip club okay you want some chicken
wings what
i love syracuse it's like i'm proud to
be from there but some of the businesses
are questionable
and there's this like nail salon and we
go get your titties out of my pantry
come on now back on stage
it's all dark we go down this driveway
behind this house that's a nail salon
business
and in the back there's a stairwell that
leads up to the second level and he's
like
we get out of the car and i was i said
what are we doing here he's like oh this
is my new place
and it just the lighting
everything was wrong like that gut thing
that happens
it happened the moment he turned the
wrong way on the highway
because i just knew i just knew that
something was a muck
and maybe my sexual
predator spidey sense was has always
been on and maybe i anticipate it
in places where it's not meant to be
anticipated but then again there is
something about your gut reaction
always your gut is the brain it's the
hardest thing to do in life is to listen
to your gut
we listen to our hearts our [ __ ]
dicks and [ __ ] we listen to our
emotions with this and
this that it's the gut is always it's
never wrong it's never wrong
it literally is the center of our being
like there our gut is a brain it
communicates with our body
and our mind and our heart so you should
always listen to it and i knew it when
we got on the highway
and the lighting of this back lot was
lit like some eli roth horror film
like there might as well been like a
neon sign that said rape and an arrow
pointing to the door it should have just
been like
it couldn't have been any more clear and
i had nowhere to go i had
i should have ran but i didn't know
right
i don't know where i just was like okay
maybe this is maybe i'm just
overthinking the situation and we go up
the stairs and we open the door
and it's it's outfitted and furnished
like
a red roof in it's just stark and
stagnant and the lighting is
fluorescent and there's not a touch of
life in it
then all the colors are muted and brown
and it just felt so
devoid of love or life and
he's showing me this like kitchenette
[ __ ] it's like a roach in the sink
and
isn't this great and i'm like this place
is in my mind i'm like this place is
where rape's gonna happen i mean i
didn't think that but that's what it
felt like it felt just
dark and empty and he's like why don't
you try out the bed and right then i was
like oh [ __ ]
i said why why don't we just go to the
movie he's like no try out the bed
and i was like no i don't really i don't
feel comfortable and he's like let's
let's just
just try it out like just trust me he's
like and did that whole thing like don't
make me feel bad and like
that manipulative thing and you know you
really want to make me upset i'm showing
you this new place
and doing that whole like you know
reverse psychology
you're the bad guy and i sit down and
it just forces himself on me and he's a
big big dude
big dude big fella fat neck
thick thick neck couldn't there's
there was no fighting him off there was
nothing
and i don't the the
your being in your brain and your body
has such an amazing way
and so many important processes to help
you deal with trauma
i've heard this before where you really
just have an out-of-body experience
and you're gone but your carcass is
there you're gone
i don't even know where i went i i don't
remember it
at all that that particular time but
you're not kicking and fighting
or initially i tried but there's no
there's no
fight i was so exhausted
that i couldn't there's no more fight in
me and that's when you just sort of like
let go
and let it it's easier to let it go and
let it happen than it is to fight
um i don't know how long it lasted
i just remember laying there and
feeling so numb and cold
and i remember he said something he was
in the bathroom and he was just like
oh i haven't seen that much blood in a
long time oh my god
and i just i didn't know what that meant
i didn't know what that meant
i was like did i die maybe i died
and he brings me home we didn't even go
to the [ __ ] movie
sucks because i think it was a horror
movie and those are my favorite but i
guess i was a star of my own
can't say i was never in the movies
he said that's terrible
oh my god it was
it was one of the only times in my life
where i can't remember
what happened and i don't remember what
i felt during that time
but afterwards he dropped me off home
and
i saw what the the blood part that he
was referring to
and i called my friend because i didn't
know i was like i don't know what this
is and
and she was like that's what happens
when you have sex for the first time
he broke your hymen i was like that
[ __ ]
he broke that i was like well how do i
fix it she's like no it's gone i was
like
[ __ ] you can't it's not even like in a
relationship where you get your cds back
i want my alana's more set you all know
[ __ ] back give me my crash into me back
i um i s
i didn't know it was rape right then
but my friend tia really helped me
during that time
acknowledged that that's what it was
yeah she really helped me
and did you report him or i went to my
health
teacher mrs leyton and she was this
total hippie with like this long hair
and these thick-ass glasses
and she had a really nice soft voice and
she had a way of
making kids feel included and she was a
great health teacher and she talked
about the butthole in a very poetic way
she made those weird slides all like the
onion you know the
infections you get you know like sex
slide show you get they're like
here's what happens if you have sex it's
just a pregnant girl and a bloomin onion
that comes out of your [ __ ] and
you're like well
great i feel prepared she had a great
way of making that
fun and she was one of the only teachers
who i felt comfortable going to and i
told her
what happened and this was the next
morning and
she told me what to do and
gave me the numbers of people at like
planned parenthood and recommended that
i go
and at least get some testing done
because it was unprotected
and recommend that i talk to my mom
about it
it took me two years i think to talk to
my mom yeah
it took me two years he messaged me
years later on facebook
i think i still have the message yeah
was that the only time you did you like
not
go to that club ever again like was that
it where did you ever see him again
i saw him i think for another week
after that and the last straw was i was
hanging out with him
and i'm sure a lot of people are
listening like oh this is a problem you
should have just ran you don't know
yeah you can't you have when you're 16
even as an adult you don't know how
you're gonna react
trauma is on a molecular level there's
no way to
you can have all the tools and your cute
little gauze
kit and your in your buck knife in a
[ __ ] bow and arrow
but until you're in the moment in the
battle you don't know how you're gonna
react you don't know what those
scars of that war what they're gonna
look like how they're gonna affect you
and how you're going to respond to that
there's no way
to truly prepare for that type of trauma
so i stayed with him for a week because
i was terrified
and i didn't know what to do and i was
at his house with his friend
who always used to defend me because he
was like this you gotta
this this is not right for you this
person
and this particular day um
he had said something to me he said
something really derogatory and i was so
mad and i like shoved him
and then he grabbed me by my neck and
pic he was huge he was a big
[ __ ] grabbed me by the neck and
shoved me up against the wall by my neck
damn instead if you ever touch me again
i will [ __ ] hurt you real bad
and was choking me and then he let me
down
and then i left i left
i don't even know how the [ __ ] i got
home that was
it i was done i didn't report him i
should have
i think any girl who's going through
[ __ ] like that
you have to report you it that is the
only thing that really changes
that's right and makes a difference what
what did he say when he reached out to
your acknowledge any of the behavior
something along the lines of and you
know if i did anything
that was bad i was in a really messed up
time
nothing specific nothing indicating that
it was rape that he did rape me that
he was physically abusive towards me
nothing like that
but it was i i have the message
somewhere
it didn't really give me any closure i
went to years of therapy
you know i still i have i have a uh
amazing
therapist and um personal coach that i
go to now brett
costin who has helped me get through a
lot in therapy in new york that i've
done for years
but it was you know it's something that
only up until about
five years ago could i recall without
bursting out into tears because it
those wounds unless you deal with them
are so fresh
and they're so palpable and that's i'm
such an advocate for
finding some treatment that works for
you i'm such an advocate for that and in
feeling not normalizing rape
but normalizing the conversation around
things like this that happen in women's
lives
anyone's life but i can only speak from
the female perspective
and from my experience it's been a very
tumultuous relationship with the world
that i've had
in these milestones having you know
the first dick i see and first dick i
touch and for stick i feel
not be under my control control
yeah or approval or approval or somebody
i love
yes someone cares about you yeah forget
you caring about them
right these guys didn't give a [ __ ]
about right you're
nothing yep god so that you know
so can i ask you then when the first
time you actually
really did have consensual sex and and
what that was like for you were you
scared were you nervous or or was it the
other way were you so
thrilled to finally be with someone that
you know that cared about you and
you had control of the situation you
know
it took me a couple of years to get
there to feel comfortable with a person
to enjoy sex to realize that a sexual
relationship could be healthy could be
respectful could be consensual
um it was yeah one of my first
boyfriends who i'm still friends with
was an amazing
individual he he
sho he that was like one of the first
relationships that was based on pure
respect and
love and openness and
you know he truly made me if it weren't
for him i don't know
what how the rest of my dating life or
personal life would have gone
because he really was like this beacon
in that point in my life because i
i was 18 19 and i
decided that i wanted to try and do
stand-up or get out of the city because
all this stuff was happening like i
i gotta go maybe it's the town
is it the [ __ ] water is this
happening in flint michigan maybe
there's too much legionnaires disease in
our goddamn top tap water
i don't know what's going on but i gotta
get the [ __ ] out so
yeah i met i met this guy who was a
mutual friend and i moved to boston and
that's where i
you know had my first love and and
respectful relationship and that's where
i found comedy and i think those two
that
the juncture of those two things feeling
supported
and having a healthy relationship
allowed me to discover i had some talent
allowed me to spread my wings a little
bit and feel
safe yeah and have the ability to
get weird and be the goof get that girl
back
yeah to really talk about it and yeah
yeah let
let people hear from you for a [ __ ]
change right
[ __ ] that's been going on it was a form
of therapy it was a form of
taking back control because you're in
control of that whole room and
everything that's said and everything
that's heard so your powers all in your
hands
i think that's why i loved it so much
the relationship was respectful the
relationship was
a cohesive thing between me and the
audience and
i was able to be who i was and feel safe
in the room
and i think that's why i fell in love
with stand-up so much is because coming
off of all those experiences
here's this very intimate relationship
that doesn't have anything to do with
sex
and i feel safe and not only do i feel
safe
i feel free so you know
between that and therapy i really
dug deep to try and heal myself
and there were
so many guys and you know those girls
are like why do i keep dating [ __ ]
because you're the [ __ ] you are the
[ __ ]
and that's you are the common
denominator in all of your relationships
so if there are problems then yes at
some point you got to stop being like
well if you would do this or you would
do that if you have to look at yourself
and be like all right
i am a huge part of this equation and
what the
[ __ ] do i bring to the table i'd like to
go figure that out
and i say all the time too like you're
never going to be perfect
but the goal at least for me is to
minimize
the frequency of those mistakes
of and and the impact of them as well
down the line you know like
to try to eventually get as good as you
can with that
um because it's crept in all of our
relationships after that even to
adulthood well i want to
do you mind telling about the one
relationship with bipolar
oh yeah yeah that was a that was a wild
one
um i truly think you date at the level
you think you deserve
ooh i think you date the type of
relationship you think you're worthy of
and the person who's in your life is
reflective of how you feel about
yourself
and that's what i learned from my
relationships
is i didn't go why
why is it why are all these [ __ ] out
there i said
why do i keep attracting the [ __ ]
i'm the flame but that's
maturity and growth and i mean
a lot of people don't get there well it
takes a lot of [ __ ] money to get
together it sure does
a lot of times
to like to relive that yes that
realization
even saying it when did you know what
age it didn't hit me to a mom
when i walked in here right when i just
said it right now
six minutes ago when we start
it took me a long time for that too
longer than i i care to admit or even
your ego
just boy ego is a [ __ ] ego's a
[ __ ] and i've said it before it
comes in the way of the self and until
you really get down to the true essence
of who you are
you will constantly be leading with your
ego and it's not to say that the ego
isn't a
a part of your life it's a health it's a
healthiest it can be
certain you know levels but it also you
can't have it be your
your the way you lead in the day you
really have to strip yourself down and
ask in the morning how am i
occurring in the world what am i doing
to hold myself
back and how can i start to live in a
way where i live more fluidly
where i'm more i'm disciplined but also
also very soft with myself it's that's
it's that balance between being soft
with yourself and being disciplined that
truly
strips the ego away and you find your
true self and
in that relationship the last
relationship
that i where i ended toxicity where i
was like this is enough
was the most important relationship i've
ever had
in my life because of the
danger how dangerous it was i don't know
if anyone's ever dealt with somebody
with borderline personality disorder
not bipolar i said bipolar and
borderline they
they're very similar on the spectrum
of you know mental disorders
they have a lot of crossover and they're
really hard to diagnose and they're
really hard to treat
years of psychotherapy medication
sometimes medications that don't work
because
ssris are so dangerous and they don't
always have great
effects and the side effects are
detrimental and sometimes the side
effects will
exacerbate the symptoms of the mental
illness so it's this
big kaleidoscope of [ __ ] that
if you're just a girl who wants love
it's really hard to deal with and
he was he was somebody who was
spoke a really good game you know he had
all the right things to say in the
beginning and he came in a really nice
package
and found me at a point in my life where
i had an opening and
snuck right in there and a lot of the
times people with borderline just
a personality disorder they will suck
your life force
they they are they gravitate towards
people like me
i'm a bright light i'm i'm the [ __ ]
magic i know that
and that's what he was trying to strip
from me all of the light and the magic
and trying to separate me from people in
my life
that's what they do they try and isolate
you they try and separate you from your
your happiness and your truth separate
you from people in your life and then
they slowly start to break you down
to sort of try and make you as sick as
they are and start to make you
question yourself and make you go am i
the one who's [ __ ] this all up
it's a really scary relationship to be
to be in and i will say this
anybody listening i i realize that it's
you know i'm glad we're talking about
mental illness now and culture
but it is not your job to save somebody
they have to save themselves
amen you cannot save somebody amen and
sometimes this one was a hard one for me
to learn too
some people don't want to be saved no so
no matter how much you're trying
it's not that you're doing a bad job
it's that they just
they don't want to be they don't want
they don't want to be and when they're
ready to be
they need to go do that for themselves
yes yes
and sometimes people have 100 100
sometimes people have diseases that
don't allow them
to know they need to be saved there's no
connection there right
and it got dangerous um
you know he broke into my home
he um tried to steal all my [ __ ] and my
dogs and
your dogs yeah did you you got a
restraining order i i got a restraining
order on valentine's day
because i love you because i love me
[ __ ] that getting a restraining
order
that's the best valentine's day gift you
could ever give your [ __ ] stuff
the day i fell in love with myself
i walked out of that courthouse i was
just like whoa
wow done this is what it takes sometimes
it takes you know
you can't have a breakthrough without a
breakdown and that was my
that was one say that again you can't
have a breakthrough without a breakdown
yeah that's you know right from from my
personal coach to your ears
you have to be broken all the way down
in order to
change you have to experience all the
time you have to sit in your [ __ ] for a
little while
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on and
then get up
excuse me and get out of it you can't
stay you can't stay in that
look we're going to stop right there
that is the perfect [ __ ] place to
stop
you're going to come back i want to do
an entire episode
talking about your dad and everything i
know a little bit about that yeah
please we have to yeah we probably want
to talk differently you're coming back a
bunch
i would love to come back but before you
leave
i told you at the top uh advice to your
16 year old self
after everything you just told us and
the age you were at the time of these
things what would you go back
now with with the foresight and tell
yourself
i would tell myself that you are loved
and all the love you have is within
yourself and that you're
worth everything that you've ever
imagined
and that no one can strip you of your
truth your dignity
or your self-respect besides you
and to go get fingered under those
bleachers
by a sweaty high school kid
wait god intended
oh i love you that you're you're [ __ ]
awesome thank you thank you
i mean you gave a lot here thank you i
appreciate you feeling comfortable
enough to do that
absolutely i appreciate you having me on
you're having a platform to talk about
it yeah
yeah look come back and tell more i know
we're just scratching the surface
unfortunately i know yeah i know um but
will you um
please promote whatever you want one
more time check out my sharp tongue
podcast
it's available every week itunes
stitcher soundcloud google play
also i have bong and movie bam
on youtube comes out about every friday
and you can what else check out
my patreon club the fun house the fan
club patreon.com forward slash jesse
maypaluso and i put exclusive videos
there that you can only get
there also oh and you can call me
yeah you can call me 513-916
and i'll you leave me a message i'll
play it on the pod
i love it thank you seriously thank you
very much
yeah this is awesome you're a good dad
thank you and a good friend
that's nice thank you call me sometime
when you're pooping girl i will
i don't know if we're ready for that uh
as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you